[Music]
hey everyone welcome to other
installments of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
Severus Snape and his knack for creating
all sorts of spells last week I made a
video where I explained in depth
each of the seven spells that Snape was
responsible for creating this list
included the toenail growing hex which
causes the victims toenails to grow
alarmingly fast Liang Locke which fixes
the victim's tongue to the roof of their
mouth the muffler auto charm which fills
the ears of anyone nearby with an
unidentifiable buzzing lever corpus
which lifts the victim's body into the
air libero corpus which drops them out
of the air
vulnera sanentur which heals the wounds
inflicted by Sectumsempra and lastly and
perhaps most importantly Sectumsempra
which is a vicious dark curse that acts
like an invisible sword causing
lacerations hemorrhaging and cuts upon
its target when Harry first takes
Slughorn's potions class he's without a
textbook and he's then instructed by
Slughorn to go and find a spare one in
the classroom it's at this time that
Harry finds Snape's old copy who
advanced potion making and when he
opened the textbook for the first time
he saw written inside this book is the
property of the half-blood Prince
Harry uses the book for quite some time
as for each and every one of Slughorn's
lessons the book provided easier and
clearer instructions that he could
follow the book was like having cheat
codes to all the potions lessons but
inside the book was not just advice on
how to make potions or perfect existing
spells never also spells written inside
that were totally new to Harry
these were spells that he had never seen
or heard of and the reason no one knew
about them was because they were
invented by Snape he created them spell
creation isn't ever properly addressed
in the Harry Potter books and films and
it's definitely a bit of a gray area why
some witches and wizards seem to be able
to create their own spells and some
can't is left entirely and clear while I
was initially of the impression that it
was a skill preserved for the immensely
talented and dedicated I then remembered
that the famous fraud stir killed Roy
Lockhart was also able to produce his
own spell either he was extremely lucky
or Lockhart was actually quite talented
underneath
all of that vanity Lockhart's spell
resembled the dark mark and that it
projected a clubbing holographic image
into the sky but instead of the dark
mark it displayed Lockhart's cheesy grin
but of all of the witches and wizards
that were introduced to Snape appears to
have the most impressive portfolio a
spell creation so how did he do it
how does he create spells here's my
theory first things first I think that
you need to have a really clear idea of
what you want your spell to achieve this
would include what it's for why you're
creating it and how you might plan on
using it once you've figured all of that
out you need to figure out the
incantation the spell that is the words
you utter as you're casting said spell
unless of course you want the spell to
be produced non-verbally which is also
an option for some spells
this was actually Snape's original
intention with lava corpus the following
exchange between Hermione and Snape
depicts his thoughts on nonverbal magic
now you are I believe complete novices
in the use of nonverbal spells
what is the advantage of a nonverbal
spell very well Miss Granger
your adversary has no warning about what
kind of magic you're about to perform
which gives you a split second advantage
an answer copied almost word-for-word
from the standard book of spells grade
six but correct in essentials but even
if the spell is produced non-verbally it
still needs a name and I think that the
name is important as it is tied to the
magical properties of spell in Harry
Potter
most of the spell books are written in
Latin so my best guess would be that the
best place to start would be to figure
out Latin root words that are related to
the purpose of your spell the name
Sectumsempra comes from the combination
of two Latin words sectors which means
having been cut and semper which means
always we can see very clearly here that
the incantation has a clear relationship
to the function of the spell though the
incantation derives from the Latin root
words some what I eat sect immerses
sectors and Semper versus Sempra we can
see a clear connection here perhaps this
deviation in the spell name is what
makes spell creation so tricky as if it
was just as simple as looking up some
Latin words and figure out the spells
purpose then it expect more to be doing
it only a truly
and patient witch or wizard would be up
to the challenge of figuring out what
combinations work well together hmm
extremely talented and extremely patient
does that sound like someone we know I
think that after establishing the spells
function and after figuring out the
Latin root words associated with the
spell the witch or wizard would then how
to through trial and error experiment
with different variations or deviations
of the incantation additionally I'd
imagine that the intent would have to
exactly match the incantation meaning
that if they uttered the correct
incantation without the matching intent
and it still wouldn't work the spell
creation is often dubbed as dangerous
and I can see her playing with the
delicate forces of magic might sometimes
produce unfavorable results another
angle that could possibly work for a
spell creating witch or wizard might be
to look at spells already in existence
to chair some sort of commonality dispel
that you're wanting to produce Snape's
Sectumsempra is not the only spell with
the word Sempra in it as in this series
we are also introduced to rictusempra we
know that Herod uses Sectumsempra on now
Floyd but he actually uses rictusempra
on him as well the following excerpt
depicts this hairy pointed his wand
straight at Malfoy and shouted
rictusempra a jet of silver light hit
Malfoy in the stomach and he doubled up
wheezing as Malfoy sank to his knees
Harry had hit him with a tickling charm
and he could barely move for laughing
rictusempra is derived from the latin
rictus which means the expense of an
open-mouth 'no latin symptom which as we
have already established means always
this means that the incantation in its
entirety roughly means always laughing
or love forever similar to
Sectumsempra 'he's always cut or cut
forever rictusempra is commonly used in
duels and is used to cause the victim to
buckle with laughter entirely unable to
help themselves the spell was not
invented by Snape
but perhaps he drew inspiration from the
latter portion of the incantation when
producing his own spell Sectumsempra we
know Snape as the cold calculated
professor that haunts Harry for most of
his time the school but Snape is
actually one of the most diverse
characters in the series haunted by the
actions of his past in his troubled
childhood
Snape was the potions master
Gords four whopping 15 years and his
personal copy of advanced potion-making
is just another signifier Snape was more
devoted to his work in potion-making
than anyone else it's his passion in the
Philosopher's Stone he sister following
to his potions class
I don't expect you will really
understand the beauty of the delicate
power of liquids that creep through
human veins bewitching the mind and
snaring the senses I can teach you how
to bottle fame brew glory and even put a
stopper in death what Snape is really
saying here is that if you have enough
talent and dedication you can really do
anything with potions we know that Snape
makes improvements in the potions
recipes in his book while he was a
student at the school and this directly
implies that he was an experiment he
liked to do things in his own way and
achieve things in the most efficient way
possible bearing this in mind it's
likely that Snape in an effort to create
his own spells took existing spells and
played with them until he caught his
desired result the same way that he
played with potions recipes so we need
to think Sectumsempra is there anything
similar the Snape could have derived
inspiration from the answer is yes in
Miranda goshawk book of spells
defender aka the severing charm is
described as follows with the severing
charm cutting or tearing objects is a
simple matter of one control the spell
can be quite precise in skilled hands
and the severing charm is widely used in
a variety of Wizarding traits
useful as it is the charm should be
practiced with caution at the careless
swipe of the wand can cause injury
defender was invented in the 15th
century by Wizarding seamstress Delphina
crimp defender comes from the Latin
first person active indicative for to
split cleave or open if we look at the
after effects of Sectumsempra we can
really start to draw some parallels
blood spurted from Malfoy's face and
chest as though he'd been slashed with
an invisible sword he staggered backward
and collapsed onto the waterlogged floor
with great splash his wand falling from
his limp right hand slipping and
staggering Harry got to his feet and
plunged toward Malfoy whose face was now
shining scarlet his white hand
scrabbling at his blood-soaked chest
so as you can see the two spells are
really quite similar however here are
the differences that we know of
Sectumsempra is a curse and a Findo is
just a charm additionally organs severed
with Sectumsempra can't be grown back we
see this with George Weasley
while those severed with two Findo
likely can my best guess is that Snape
was inspired by the properties of
defender but wanted to weaponize it he
hated the Marauders they were his sworn
enemies and in his spell book he even
labeled Sectumsempra with a note for
enemies my theory is that Sectumsempra
is a combination of the properties of
Toph endo and rictusempra Snape's
affinity for potions and the dark arts
paired with his hatred for the Marauders
resulted in the creation of Snape's
powerful curse he took an innocent charm
used to cut herbes and materials and
turned it into a dark curse it could
tear through human flesh the only real
glaring problem with the Latin root
argument part of this theory is that in
the Harry Potter universe there are
witches and wizards all over the world
and many of them don't speak a language
that has a Latin base this confuses
things but my thought was that in a
magical world where seemingly anything
is possible
the magical presence location and intent
of the caster accounts for the wizard or
witch's specific utterance of the
incantation this means that you would be
able to use your own root language to
produce an incantation that creates the
same spell it just wouldn't make sense
that all spells are Latin based anyway
that's it for this video if you guys
have any further questions or comments
leave them down below if you enjoy the
content please be sure to like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time your wizard Ari
[Music]